[Music]
say the fungal kingdom is an incredible
group of organisms there's about six
million of them and they have an
incredible diversity of morphology
shapes sizes and impact on the planet
they are organisms that include things
like yeast as well as mushrooms and all
kinds of organisms in between so we
brought together through CFR an
incredibly interdisciplinary team with
experts from all around the world who
have incredible depth of knowledge in
very different areas and by bringing
together this group we were able to
publish and produce a review article
where we looked at the current state of
art the state of the field and very
different areas and figured out what
were the key challenges to address
moving forward so we've seen that Canada
Oris is this mysterious fungus that
appeared first in 2009 no one knows
where it came from it appeared and it's
now spreading all over the world and
it's very alarming because it's
resistant to all of the antifungal drugs
we use to treat people if we look at
threats to biodiversity we've been
looking at a fungus a very ancient
fungus that has been killing off frog
species and there's now over 90 species
that have gone extinct around the world
so in our third category we'll look at
food security and here we can think of
virtually every food that we eat and use
for our crops is threatened by fungal
pathogens an example is bananas which
are incredibly widely used and we
actually use a very limited type of
banana which is vulnerable to this new
pathogen that's now spreading around the
world
[Music]
so it's important to note that fungi
have been really neglected throughout
history and so this is a really crucial
team to bring together these scientists
to figure out big important solutions to
the grand challenges that are facing
humanity and as we've seen with this
example of kovat 19 and the global
pandemic we know that it's crucial at
sciences forward-looking
in addressing the challenges in advance
of when they have dire consequences
[Music]